ben déjà sur la forme euh c'est le
retour de l' RTF quoi hein parce que
20h15 c'est l'heure des foyers c'est
l'heure du foyer on se retrouve on mange
donc il s'impose dans tous les foyers
français toutes les chaînes confondues
euh publ privé enfin voilà ça va être le
grand chaud Macron à cette occasion donc
sur la forme moi je suis assez c'estz
perplexe hein sur une forme de
d'autoritarisme du président de la
République qui décide comme cela pendant
euh 2h 2h 3h on sait que Monsieur Macron
peut être long sur un exercice on dit
qu'il ne l'aime pas on verra bien mais
ce que je sais c'est que moi qui ai
assisté à plusieurs conférences de
presse de ce type avec François Holland
c'est ce que je c'est ce que j'allais
vous dire c'est exactement le format
queemploya sauf que ce n'était pas la
même heure c'était un petit peu plusutôt
dans
l'après-midiprèsmidi avec des reprises
le soir par les télévisions les radios
la presse écrite là il
s'impose
y